[Music]
so the reality is that businesses are
complex people do lots of things we need
to change lots of things all the time
and everybody is stressed for time so we
we start treating things a bit more
mechanical people are automatons and
they are producing some gadgets or
they're making some output and and part
of it is lack of time part of it is lack
of attention but as a consequence I
think we're really killing the
motivation of people that people have I
think that this idea that we need to M
from the company to employees say thank
you more frequently saying we've seen
your effort here's what you contributed
to here is your name connected to is is
is important the other things we don't
spend enough time on is the commitment
of the team members to each other again
we had this functional view we're paying
for your time come here but but we don't
really get people's minds and souls and
so on and one way to do it is to get the
team members I was in California not too
long ago and I was visiting a startup
and I asked them how often do they stay
after midnight working and they said
quite often and they told me that the
night before they stayed until they said
after midnight I said how did it work
out and they said that one of the team
members was late on something and she
was going to stay until 8:00 and the
other team members decided out of
camaraderie to stay with her and one of
the guys said he called his wife I said
sorry I'm going to stay until late
they've two little kids is and he said I
have to help Maria finish this and he
said if it was for his project his wife
would have been pissed off with him but
because he was helping somebody else it
was actually a good thing right
now think about what it means that we
have this notion of social utility the
fact that we care about the so today the
other people around us sometimes more
than we care about ourselves is it
incredibly important element and that is
about a true team spirit when people
deeply care about each other and are
willing to do sacrifices to help other
people that they might not do for
themselves it may be the last thing but
the most important one is to understand
that as we move more and more to the
knowledge economy life and effort and
motivation is about good will you know
if you worked for me and you did
something incredibly basic maybe I don't
care about your goodwill but as we move
to the knowledge economy you can
modulate your efforts in attention and
care to such a degree that the question
is how do I get goodwill so you can get
somebody to sit there and code but how
do you get them to truly care to truly
think about the problem to truly try out
to try and learn something to basically
maybe slow themselves down now because
they're going to learn something later
that would help them to collaborate with
other people how do you get people to
really care to truly have goodwill a lot
of the things that we're doing are not
in the range of creating goodwill they
are in the range of creating efficiency
and efficiency in the short term not
even in the long term in the name of
short-term efficiency I think we're
often killing goodwill so I would like
to see a process in which people ask
themselves to what extent is this are
these cubicles to what extent is our
lunch and coffee and incentives and 360
evaluation whatever it is to what extent
and those thinking about compliance and
rules and making sure that nobody's
running astray and to what extent are
they about getting goodwill out of
people getting a long term long term
commitment the same things that apply to
motivating other people also apply about
motivating ourselves and so so you could
you could have a life in which you
basically are consumed by email
and you set yourself my task my joy in
life is getting to inbox zero right we
even have a term for this as if this is
a a goal of life like imagine somebody
on the deathbed say oh I've arrived at
inbox zero almost a thousand days
throughout my life and it's very easy in
the literature there's a term for this
is called structured procrastination
where you basically do lots of little
things that give you the sense that
you're making progress without actually
making the progress and it it's very
easy to get ourselves to do lots of
little tasks that gives us momentary
slightly joy I raised another email
response another email and so on without
thinking thinking long term and long
term thinking is really what causes real
joy a and it's not easy right it's not
easy I I get about 300 emails a day I
wake up I open my laptop it's always a
moment of like slight depression oh my
goodness I have to deal with all this
and I can spend my whole day doing email
an email here's an analogy right is
analogy for all the things that you have
to do but they're not giving you a true
sense of accomplishment and in the real
challenge and it's not easy is to carve
time to do the things that you would say
at the end of three months six months a
year and so on will give me a sense that
I'm actually contributing doing doing
something else so personally I do this
with writing right it's very easy to
spend the whole day right responding to
email I try to protect some time and say
I'm going to write I'm going to actually
stop I'm going to think it will take me
a while sometimes I'll write something I
said the whole time was useless I didn't
really progress enough but but from time
to time there is progress and over time
it creates a body of knowledge that you
say this is actually a very useful
useful thing to do so I think managers
for themselves need to think about the
three months six months nine months one
year five years and so on goal
and make sure they protect some time to
make progress toward those throw those
things because nobody else will protect
their time for them
[Music]